hey everybody it's Mike from waterflows
and welcome to today's video today is a
Thursday
January 19th 2023 and you know the
market reopened last night at five and
we proceeded to sell off quite orderly
getting into you know the US hours and
did get a little bit of a pop right
after the cash opened and we sold off to
new lows but after we you know
established our low for the day the
market had a nice rally you know it was
almost a 40-point rally I think you know
one the low was like uh what was that
one and three quarters we got back up to
around you know just around the 40 area
40 and a quarter it's about 39 points so
that was a nice rally and I want to talk
about some of the order flow that you
could have taken advantage of so that
you know when you're looking at a
footprint chart you got some Clues on
what you can focus on and add to your
trading so before I begin you know if
you haven't already be sure to subscribe
to the channel hit that subscribe button
below and you know if you find you get
some value out of this video be sure to
like the video
all right so let's take a look at the
footprints okay so you know one of the
things that
I use in my own trading that one of the
things that is very important to me is
understanding where value is in a bar
all right now
if you've ever you know looked at volume
profile or Market profile any done any
analysis in in those areas you
understand the term value area right and
a value area but how most people look at
it is you know the day's value area or
70 of the day's volume transacts now
with order flow you're looking at volume
anyway so why not take it as
sort of as as micro as you can and you
know look at it on a bar by bar basis
you know especially a lot of these
contracts trade very nice volume I mean
minis are trading thousands of contracts
in a minute right this is e-minis this
is you know 1101 it trades 6 700
contracts 1102 6860 contracts you know
even some of these smaller bars 1800
contracts that's good that's decent
volume you could you could use that in
your analysis now for me when I Define a
value area it is where seventy percent
of the volume in the bar transact just
if I was using a volume profile for the
day I would still use 70 right I'm not
going to deviate it and try to fine
point it now some people say well you
should really use 68 okay honestly the
difference between 68 and 70 percent
you know on a bar by bar basis is pretty
much going to be exactly the same you
know once in a while you may tick up to
one more price level or remove one more
price level but it did very it really
varies now
on the order of Illustrator software
okay if you're using my software you'll
find this very informative and very
eye-opening if you're not already using
it I talk about this in my weekly uh
sessions before you know our order flow
users but what I like to look for is
value areas that are abandoned that are
not traded back into
in the next bar Okay because I'm going
to look at these as one I can look at
them as support or resistance you know
support if it's uh coming on on an up
bar on an up move or resistance if it's
coming in on a red bar on a down move
and there are little nuances right
you're not going to just
indiscriminately trade each and every
one you know ideally you'd be looking
for them at you know sort of as the
market is making a move a turn or a move
because you know at the end of the day
you know you don't want to just take
value areas that are abandoned
in the middle of
sideways activity right no matter what
system or method or whatever you're
trading if the market is not moving
trading sideways it's not going to be
very effective
so that being said okay so you can see
the value areas right in each bar it's
this big green box in the bar that's not
the actual candle the candle's inside
but I can see how the values are forming
note value is migrating higher value
areas highs and lows of each green
candle as it's what you expect to see
isn't going higher right just as the
market is moving down value areas are
moving lower you're seeing the value
area lows of red candles ideally you
expect them to be migrating lower I mean
that's basic right that's not like some
hidden Rhythm of the market that's what
you expect to see on moves now where it
gets a little bit interesting you know
sometimes you're going to have gaps in
the value areas right there's no gaps
between the two bars but the value areas
of the bars you do see gaps right and
there's patterns you can discern from
there and it's actually because you know
people will say well you know
isn't the market a random walk well
I don't think it is I mean in general
overall yeah maybe it's pretty random
but on a smaller scale people are buying
and selling based on their perception of
what they think the market is valued at
right and it doesn't matter whether
there's e-minis or crude oil or euro
currency or soybean meal or palm oil or
you know tin or copper you know people
have people have traded have their
perception of value and when value
starts to move in their minds
that's what they're basing their
training decisions on so if I start to
see you know gaps in value in a
direction to me that that's solid
information that I can use all right so
getting back to abandoned value areas
now you know if you've ever studied
Market profile volume profile you're
probably familiar with the term naked
POC or virgin POC
I use
I could I could call it naked PLC I
could call it virgin POS uh naked value
area or
virgin value area but I prefer the term
abandoned because it's being abandoned
and yeah I don't want my kids over
hearing me or my wife overhearing me
think I'm talking about some porno stuff
but um
I just prefer the term abandoned it's
just easier for me to uh to say now
so what I'm looking for right is a bar
where you have a value area like here
and the next bar doesn't trade back into
that whether it's an up bar or a down
bar okay but you can see how pretty much
every bar most bars I don't know what
the percentage is 95 percent
gets retraced back into the value area
gets retraced back into and sometimes it
gets accepted sometimes it gets rejected
obviously a clear sign of rejection of a
value area is
when it doesn't trade back into it so
that's important information right it's
information that you can use and
um
take trades off of right you could wrap
this around you know your own trading
strategy so on the order flow is Trader
I've seen a few softwares out there that
have copied this concept actually in
their software of course they don't
use it because they don't trade they
just make software by copying other
people's ideas
um
change it to until tested
okay
that's why I don't get you know I see a
lot of people copying software out there
um but it's like
you know and because my software's been
out there since 2015 and you know a lot
of my stuff's been added to other
people's software okay fine but it's
like it's just adding it for the sake of
adding it because I have it you know
it's like be original
create your own things I I there are
some softwares out there that are
original order flow stuff that that are
also brilliant okay I'm not saying mine
is this
the best you know but it suits me
because this is how I trade you know
everything you see in here is in here
because this is what I wanted to put in
based on my own analysis
all right so enough of that you can see
here right cash opened 8 30 rallied up
from 19 all the way up to around the 30s
33 and a half 33 and three quarters
started coming off right Gap in value
then you see this value area that's
abandoned here but again you don't know
it's going to be abandoned until this
this bar closes here the bar afterwards
that doesn't trade back into okay so Gap
and go right a little Gap here go with
it you got the value area that's been
abandoned
and you know again gives you a nice you
know not a monster move but gives you a
nice five quick points you know then
starts to go sideways then you're going
sideways in here you get one
here a bullish one now again I'm looking
at this is potential resistance now okay
this could be potential support you can
see how it trades right up to the value
Area High all right now be careful right
when you're trading these don't just
trade everything indiscriminately like
oh my gosh you know there's a abandoned
value right here I got to get long you
know
without giving away a secret sauce
basically
think about it okay okay you have your
abandoned value area here right rather
than just say okay I've got my bullish
value area that's being abandoned in the
next bar I got to get long well you
still got to read what's happening in
the market
right what's this next bar doing well
it's opened up down here and it's
trading back into the value
it's accepting this previous value as
opposed to over here
right okay it was abandoned the next Bar
opens up
kind of makes an attempt back up towards
it but then you know again it makes a
move down this one is going to be you
know a much better trade to take than
this one where Market opened up rallied
up and then it's closing right on the
value it's like you can just see it
coming right back into it right even
though technically it's an abandoned
value area here
the way the price is moving it's coming
right back into it right so it's not
going to be a very effective trade to
just take blindly
you still got to think about what you're
looking at rather than just take them
all indiscriminately blindly just like
here right this is a nice one starts
moving up okay right you've got your
abandoned value area here next bar is
higher than the next bar is starting to
go higher right you got a nice little
move there but let's take a look
um you know a little bit later right to
when we hit that low of the day okay and
you can see how this Market is it's
moving in those directions okay
but I want to talk about the low of the
day here okay so this was this was the
law of the day around just before 11
o'clock and it was quite interesting
because you know big selling balance
coming into stack selling and balance
coming into the low make that new low
there's some big volume coming in here
39.02 on the offer side you know 1100
and again I look at Twitter oh my gosh
you know if we break if we get back into
the 3800s you know everyone's gonna be a
lot of fear well yeah no and we're
just trading a couple days ago 4 000 you
know and we're losing already 150 close
to 140 points
um yeah I mean at some point people are
going to Chuck it in I mean it doesn't
take a rocket scientist to to understand
that but anyway
so we make this low at one and three
quarters and we start going up and then
go sideways right now what do we got a
value area here that's abandoned
followed by another one so you got two
in a row and you got Gap here between
this value area gap between this value
area
that's a strong sign because you don't
really get a lot of two value areas
abandoned in a row okay I'll just say
that right now because I've done the
tests on it and I know it's quite strong
and
really designed to get in off of is this
bar right here you don't even need to
wait over here you see it came back in
it got within the value area high so I
talk about these areas you know if
they're bullish ones are going to be
your support if they're bearish ones
they're going to be resistance right it
just comes right to that top 39
10 is actually this is the price where
we traded back into you know within a
tick of the high of value a high of uh
nine and three quarters and went back up
right and we just see it just comes back
down sort of holding you'll notice these
value areas are all traded back into
traded back into
right then you get a bearish one here
okay well I know I have this support
here back here at nine and three
quarters right in here down to seven and
a half and I've got the one up from
earlier as well to hide behind
okay so even I got the bearish one here
maybe you know you might want to take a
short but again yeah I know I'm going to
run into support down in here so even if
I take that you know what capacity is
there for a trade you know getting short
around you know in this bar maybe 11
you know or 12 even well this is 12.
if I move down you know it could you
know it could stall around 08
potentially then you got another
support-ish area here so again I mean if
you take it you know this is one where
it's like well you know
I don't know it's not one that I'd be
I'd be more interested to watch if you
know I'd still be more interested in the
long because the long is a little bit
stronger than what I'm seeing in here
and this one is sort of coming after a
long period of sideways activity and
then it starts turning back right it
comes into that support area you end up
with this doji right here
and it's starts ticking back up okay and
what you get you get another abandoned
value area here so even if you got short
in here you know when it starts coming
back up you know maybe you know you're
like oh you know I should have kept
my original long maybe you got long
again or maybe just you know
it said screw it and cover it or you
know maybe get stopped out up here I
don't know but once it gets on the other
side of this previous resistance and now
you've got
a new support area it's a sign for you
to get long you know back in here right
once this bar closes you can get long
here at 16 that area
and it shoots right up into the 23s goes
sideways a bit
get another bullish sign another bullish
sign
and then it's just sort of Off to the
Races it's just moving higher and higher
right what was interesting about this is
you had that one zone and it came right
back into it
and it left you with another zone right
another abandoned value area to move
higher okay so you can see that's the
one o'clock here it just sort of holds
it's kind of holding right if you were
to
even you know I don't say you could
overlap these two but you know if you
were here
to hear this area right I mean if you
were sort of scrunch those bars together
see it comes right back into this area
in here before it launches back up again
up into the 40s right
right here I'll say 40s but you know 40
literally
okay and then you know you're getting
some bearish ones in here you know a
small move here this one you know you
would have taken a taken a loss on the
chin
but this one you could have got back
what you lost here
and then you know you sort of coming
into the close of the day you know to 2
. it's quite interesting I saw a big
squaring up on today's clothes a lot of
volume went through on today's close I
think it has had a head of options
expiration Tomorrow People just want to
flatten their book but
the point is look for these value areas
that get abandoned right so if you're
not using value areas you know I don't
know you know I see I've been using
order flow for over a decade now and
it's just like people say oh you don't
need order flow that's Overkill you know
there's nothing valuable in it well okay
fine you know if you don't need it it's
just like well do do you need a Porsche
or just do you need a Kia right they
both provide transportation but the only
you know a nicer car or not you know
that's why I always say you know the
information is there it's available to
you as a Trader why not use it
right you can see there's that zone from
earlier Market came right back to that
value area high here literally one tick
above it
and you know got that point move off of
that and you can't make this this stuff
up sometimes
um you know if you want to use Market
generated information go do some
research into value areas right if you
get my software and you only use one
part of it use the value areas right
it's very useful and can help you in
your trading help you understand what's
happening in the market you know maybe
tomorrow I'll talk about gaps in the
value areas okay because
you know back in the 80s and 90s on the
same back in the 70s and 80s you know
there was a lot of
studies done on Gap analysis and now
with the markets basically trading
around the clock you know other than
markets like I don't know Hogs and
cattle that close and don't have an
overnight session
you know these markets you don't really
talk about gaps that much right because
you know there's always the evenings you
know s P's pretty much trade Around the
Clock except for that one hour
currencies same thing
um you know even the grains even though
they got the later opening
um they still and they close you know in
the morning for about uh for a little
while was that like an hour or so but um
you don't get uh you don't get those Gap
plays but when you start looking at
things like value areas that's when you
could start doing some sort of Gap
analysis right and it's it's fascinating
because you know a lot of the stuff that
if you've ever done any sort of research
on gaps right you can see a lot of
things that
translate well into the order Flow by
using value areas and doing some Gap
analysis
so anyway guys
I'll end it there be sure to subscribe
to the channel if you haven't already
and hit the like button if you got
something useful out of this video and
I'll catch you guys on the next video
bye bye